I had some discussions over the last few
days over the weekend with some friends
and some people I met I guess we'll call
it in the real world not on the show and
there were a few people who said to me
you know I'm feeling guilty because as
soon as I meet someone who says I voted
for President Donald Trump I'm judging
them and I'm feeling guilty because I'm
judging them and I'm here to tell you
that it's fair to judge every single
person you meet that voted for Donald
Trump and the question is judge them for
what and I hope if you're going to
respond to this segment you're going to
respond to what I actually say and I'm
about to say rather than what you think
I'm saying because I may not be saying
what you're hearing
so let's spit let's let's really explore
this okay you can learn a lot about my
ideology from my rejecting Donald Trump
in the election right it's fair to judge
me because I rejected and didn't vote
for Donald Trump I don't believe the
u.s. is well served by having a
buffoonish reality show clown in the
highest position of power you can judge
me as thinking that as believing that
based on my vote against Trump and you
can accurately know that I don't respect
Donald Trump style of politics I can
reliably judge every Trump voter as
voting for Trump for some combination of
the following and again I'm about to
give you some categories here not every
single one of these applies to every
Trump voter number one yes they could be
genuinely bad people because and that's
why they voted for Donald Trump they
want to see others suffer this is the
minority right but that's possible it's
possible there's people in the alt-right
of including not everybody but including
racists xenophobes Islamophobes etc if
you're someone like that Trump was
definitely your candidate in 2016 we
have tons of polling and survey data
data that confirmed that for us of
course not all Trump supporters are
bigots but if you're a bigot you almost
definitely vote
for Donald Trump in the 2016 election
number two some Trump supporters voters
are a combination of selfish and
ignorant in varying proportions right
selfish because they think electing
Donald Trump will help them specifically
probably not true unless you're already
quite wealthy as we figured out or
ignorant because you don't realize that
Trump won't help you you you you are
believing or you've been bamboozled by
Trump into thinking that and don't
realize it so that can be a combination
a blend so to speak of selfishness and
ignorance number three you might
actually not be ignorant right you
understand everything about Donald Trump
and you understand the impact that
Trump's proposed policies will have on
different groups in the population
income group income groups minority
groups etc but you voted for him anyway
because you actually have something to
gain personally right some kind of quid
pro quo your business will benefit
something like that and voting for
someone solely based on that is
something that we can judge as people in
the world you might not even judge it
negatively and this is this is the key
and why I said react to what I'm saying
not to what what you're hearing which is
it's fair to judge Trump voters but the
key question is judge them for what
maybe Trump will drastically decrease
taxes on the rich or big corporations
and you're in one of those groups and
that's why you voted for Trump no
ignorant at all you completely
understand what Trump's proposed policy
effects would be and number four you're
not necessarily concerned only about
yourself but you think that Trump would
be better for this country than Hillary
Clinton would have been but you don't
understand a lot of basic concepts right
these could be economic concepts foreign
policy trade you totally get what Trump
is proposing but you just don't
understand many of these concepts and
thus you don't get that the ideas
espoused by Donald Trump would be a
disaster for the United States if he's
able to do everything he says he's going
to do and hopefully we're all praying
here I'm kind of joking but we're all
hoping here that he's not able to do
that
that's probably the least condemnable
type of Trump supporter right because
you mean well you really believe you
understand the Trump policies you get
what he's proposing you like it more
than what Hillary Clinton proposed and
that's why you voted you just don't
understand a lot of the broader concepts
that would explain to you why these are
genuinely bad ideas in many cases I'm
still going to judge you for being a
voter that doesn't understand the the
background and many of these broader
issues and didn't engage enough to do
your research but again these are not ad
hominem judgments so to speak I would
say that in general you have three types
of Trump supporters that fall into that
that last camp which is you mean well
you just believe that the Trump policies
will genuinely be better for the country
country than the Clinton policies those
are traditional Republicans right you
usually vote Republican in presidential
elections you you maybe find Trump to be
flat or even obnoxious you would have
rather seen someone like Ted Cruz or
Rubio or Jeb Bush on the Republican
ticket but you're going to vote
Republican regardless because you
genuinely believe that there is a more
benefit to gain to be seen by the
country from a trump presidency you know
this type of person right there's a lot
of older folks a lot of people from the
south a lot of blue-collar people people
who are just lifelong so-called
mainstream Republicans people who were
affected by the sort of maybe Clinton
propaganda etc okay then there are those
who don't really follow politics too
much but they've seen a lot of the
propaganda around how Hillary's crooked
email stuff maybe Benghazi etc and you
voted Trump not because you love Trump
but because you really fell for the
Hillary Clinton is corrupt stuff without
realizing but any criticism you can make
a pillory Clinton you could make five or
ten fold about Donald Trump and this
relates to this sort of I hate to use
the term alternative fact or alternate
realities that many Trump supporters are
living in they've really been bamboozled
not in terms of Trump policy but in
terms of who Hillary Clinton was very
very common in twenty
sixteen these are the types of people
were if you ask why did you vote for
Trump specifically what policies do you
like the delisting policies they say and
he tells it like it is he's not afraid
of offending people
he's cutting to the chase he's not a
standard politician Hillary Clinton far
from a perfect candidate in many ways I
said it at the beginning of the primary
baggage changing of positions pandering
apparent lack of sincerity a lot can be
said about why Hillary Clinton turned
off voters but she was exponentially
more qualified than Donald Donald Trump
exponentially more experienced far
better candidate than Trump in every way
there's nothing you could criticize
Hillary Clinton over that you couldn't
criticize Trump for a way more
significantly so maybe I shouldn't
actually because I share sometimes I
also when someone says I voted for Trump
I immediately say well which one of
these categories do you fit in because
you fit into one of these categories no
doubt I also sometimes will feel guilty
but then I realize you know maybe I
really shouldn't feel guilty about it
look at the disasters that Trump is
already committed in the early days of
its presidency each and every Trump
voter is to blame no matter how they
ended up on Election Day or whatever day
it was that they voted saying yes I'm
voting for Trump they are one of those
voters that is responsible for what we
now have in the White House the first
orange President of the United States
send me your thoughts on this and please
react to what I actually said not to
what you might have heard which is I'm
insulting Trump supporters or all Trump
supporters or bad people because that's
not what I said you need to listen to
listen to or watch the clip over again
before responding by all means please do
that